[Music]
from the director of all those Russell
Crowe movies you never saw and the
writer of lost son satisfying final
episode comes a sort of prequel that
doesn't use the best parts of the Alien
franchise Prometheus a film whose first
30 minutes are mostly landscape shots
where two scientists are on a quest to
find extraterrestrial life based on
really flimsy evidence a trillion dollar
mission manned by the worst crew in
space a lazy captain who leaves his crew
to die a STONER geologist with
state-of-the-art computer maps radio
communication mapping balls and GPS
still gets lost an inconsistent
biologist who is scared of a 2,000 year
old dead body no it's good but falls in
love with a clearly dangerous alien
snake and an idiot woman who can only
run in straight lines a film with so
much CGI
the visual effects Department forgot to
change anyone's heart rate one men will
achieve his lifelong dream of finding
aliens but somehow feels like a failure
after only investigating for six hours
and one woman will give force exposition
prema and will create life the pregnant
and get her uterus cut open which will
hurt a lot when standing but not jumping
falling or repelling a film so forced it
attempts to connect to the Alien
franchise by having someone drink a
troubled like ooh before impregnating
the main character with a squid baby
it's a pregnant an engineer creates an
alien had only kind of looks like the
aliens in the real movies even though
they already showed a picture of the
Queen alien on a wall and at the quest
that has no answers or payoff to
anything like the green goo the giant
head statue the disregard of evolution
this green crystal the engineers hatred
of humans the black goo the black goo
creating an eye worm the black goo
creating a zombie the black goo
dissolving an engineer the reason why
people in the Holograms are running into
a room full of black goo
David murdering someone for no reason
the engineers leaving ancient humans
maps to their weapons facilities and why
it matters he was vicars dead father
stary the newly great face data dr.
Manhattan black oil from the x-files
Charlie the rod Benjamin Button and
super vagina Prometheus God please you
stay away from Blade Runner check out
our new screen junkies episode on how
not to get taken
or else I'll take you I'm a very
particular set of skills as always leave
a comment with the movie you like to see
next time or a word like to hear me say
in my sweet voice hello Java nerd what
what in the butt the dude abides fuzzy
wuzzy was a bear fuzzy wuzzy had no hair
fuzzy wuzzy wasn't very fuzzy was he